こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
はい、というわけで
えー 以前
動画でもお知らせした通り
あのーー
手に入れたんですけども
あの まあ、結構いろいろ考えたり
コメント欄とか見て
やっぱ僕、あのー まあ
言うて 1000万持ってる訳ですよ
1000万持ってて
で その使い道をどうしようかな
みたいな動画を出したんですけども
あのー まあいろいろ考えて
まあ いろいろ相談しあった結果
えーー
1000万円の
使い道が決まりました
で 勝ち取った
【長い長いドラムロール】
嘘です！
いろいろ考えて
こう1000万円ボガーンていうか
超でかい企画をやろうと
思ったんですけども
まあ 正直それよりもっと こう
もっとみなさんを喜ばせるために
いや それ以上に
もっと俺自身楽しむために
どういう企画をすればいいか
って思ったんですけど
あの 1000万円を使って
100万円
100万円の企画を
10発
やろうと思います！
【はじめ拍手】
よっしゃー！
ごめんね…
それを言いたかっただけw
あのー ほんと なんかね こう
「1000万円ではじめなにすんだろう」
みたいに気になってた方も
多いと思うんですけど
1000万円バーッと使おうと思っても
なかなか こう思いつかなかったんですけど
あの 100万円って考えたら
（心の声：あれ…）
（意外とできんじゃんww）
なんか1000万円っていうか
100万円10個って考えたら
あれ なんか10回ぐらい
すげーおもしろいことできるんじゃね？
って思っちゃって
あの 僕の頭の中では
ある程度もう企画はもうできています
100万円で何するかっていう企画は
4つぐらい
なかなかこう 1個の企画に100万円使う
みたいなバカみたいな大赤字企画
僕たまにしかやんないんで
過去2回やってますけど
まあ 今回せっかく手に入れた
1000万円なんで
見てる皆さんが楽しめるような企画
あの やってる俺が楽しい企画
大炎上寸前ギリギリの企画
できれば避けたいですけど
というちょっと 飛び抜けた企画を
10発できればいいかなって
思っております
使い道は山ほどだ
あっはっは【はじめ狂気】
というわけで、あの分かんないです
多分100万円超える企画とかも
あると思うんですけども
そうなると あの 10本の企画の数を
1本に300万円回せることに
ちょっと減っちゃったりもするんですけど
まあ という感じで ちょっと
あの 100万円企画っていう感じで
やっていこうと思います
まだ 全然いつできるか
分かんないんですけど
見てる皆さんを絡める企画とかも
あると思うので
まあ みんなでバカして楽しめればいいな
と思っております
ごめん！
今日 遊戯王の大会なんで
忙しいです
あと今日 夜にコンテスト動画
つくってくれたみんなと
打ち上げもあるんで
手伝ってくれた みなさんに感謝して
あの 投票して下さった
みなさんに感謝して
あのー 楽しい動画をつくっていければ
いいなと思っております
きっちり1000万
使っていこうと思います
じゃ
大会行ってきます！
じゃあな！
今日は優勝するぞ！
【ED】